hi i'm jaz sinclair and i play rosalind
walker
hi i'm lachlan watson and i play theo
putnam
hey guys i'm gavin leatherwood and i
play nicolas scratch hello
i'm kiernan shipka and i play sabrina
spellman and we're the cast of the
chilling adventures of sabrina and we're
here to take a buzzfeed quiz to find out
which sabrina and rick male characters
wore a combo of
how would your bffs describe you the
options we have you guys
are sincere charming loyal intelligent
ambitious and charismatic can we like
answer for each other
yeah i think this one is only
appropriate to
answer for each other i think as i'd say
you're severe
yay i like sincere what about for gavin
i would say charismatic i think we have
to go with charismatic charming
terms because charming is charismatic as
well
okay i'll take that i think kiernan also
has to be charming because it's
obviously a little witchy that she just
charms
people into just oh i might argue
intelligent too though because
i was thinking intelligent of
information thank you
i will take that because we should we
can bury it up
lachlan laughlin loyal i'd say loyal i
don't know you were gonna say that
swim for nothing choose something to
order up
pops burger with fries milkshake
pancakes
eggs and bacon salad or grilled cheese
i do not think it's a pop strip without
a milkshake
i remember one that one time we were
filming a scene and they
make real milkshakes for us at
cerberuses we were just drinking like a
lot of them and they're like
guys the milkshakes are dwindling and
the continuity is very acceptable can
you please not drink like
a milkshake a shot i'm gonna go pancakes
because i'm hungry and this picture of
pancakes is very sexy
i'm gonna have to say eggs and bacon
classic classics lachlan which one did
you choose
i chose milkshake don't yell at me
agreement with that which adults would
you trust with a secret ann hilda odd
zelda madam satan
f.p jones hiram lodge and alice cooper
i'm good zelda okay you're going zelda
i'm going hilda i'm going hilda
i don't know why i want to say madame
satan to trust with a secret but i do
so she can use it against you and kill
you later pick another netflix teen
show to binge watch julian the phantoms
outer banks never have i ever the
society
teenage bounty hunters and on my block
i'm gonna compliment that
oh yeah yeah i love mindy kaling she's
brilliant
i'm gonna have to say outer banks
because it's based in north carolina and
i'm
in the middle of a hurricane in north
carolina right now so it just feels
really
really fitting i'm gonna go on my block
because i met
some of the cast from it and they were
just so
cool so if they're that cool their
show's gotta be great
i'll pick the society again for the
intuition
intuitive reason i have no real reason
to pick it but i'm just gonna pick that
one because something is calling me to
it
choose a class to take satanic choir
necromancy
ritual magic sacred geometry demonology
or herbalism i love that you changed you
got more and more fish
with every one i found
i'm gonna grab them that seems really
cool i like plants
herbalism i'm gonna do ritual magic i'm
gonna have to go with ritual magic
too i i don't have much interest in
necromancy i don't think that that's uh
something that i'd like to get good at
you know opposites attract i guess or
something i'm gonna have to say
necromancy
i would love to bring back the dead and
talk to some people
there's some interesting folks who have
passed and i'd like to bring them back
to life have a conversation with them
which side of these love triangles is
your favorite
sabrina obviously uh sabrina and harvey
harvey and roz
archie and veronica archie and betty or
betty and jughead
i mean i owe it to every nebrina stan
ever to
choose from i mean come on sabrina's
spelling
has spoken she said it here folks she
said it i'm gonna go harvey and roz
i'm also gonna go harvey and roz yeah
i was going to go harvey and roz too
because without
harvey and roz who knows what would have
happened with nick and sabrina
very true so i'm going to say harvey
assumption because i'm going to believe
that harvey and roz were fate no matter
what
so i think maybe then sabrina would have
ended up with the sexy swimmer
just because you said i'm gonna go
sabrina there choose something
important from the chilling vintages of
sabrina we have the spelman mortuary
the academy of unseen arts salem
cerberus books and the book of the beast
and the unholy regalia i'm gonna go with
salem
he's the real mvp he really comes
through in this last part too in a
couple
instances has had my back since day one
salem i'm going with the academy of
unseen arts y'all
me too i'm going cerberus it's too
important
everything crucial happened at services
don't happen
i'm a combination of nick
and veronica it's kind of spicy i kind
of dig it
i got the same results really you and i
are kindred spirits baby
i think me and jazz are kindred spirits
because i got razz
and tony didn't tell you oh my god
learning
in the game you're a perfect combo of
nick and veronica you're
charming ambitious and headstrong like
nick
you love with your whole heart and are
constantly striving to be the very
best version of yourself and like
veronica
your charisma and dedication has gotten
you far in life you are fiercely
independent
you're a perfect combo of rosin tony
you're fierce kind and loyal like ross
you're extremely inquisitive and you
love to explore the world around you and
like tony you're someone who sees the
very best in people
your friends often turn to you when they
need advice because you are the best
listener around
i'll take it i'll tell you that's pretty
good thank you guys for
watching us take the quiz we hope you
take it along with us and check out the
chilling adventures of sabrina part 4
out on netflix on december 31st
you